-Hey, welcome back.
Welcome back.
-Thank you, buddy.
I'm happy to be back.
Oh, my God, please. I'm happy.
Thank you for doing the show.
I have thousands of things
I want to talk to you about.
But first, I'm happy
that we're friends.
We know each other a little bit,
and I know that --
And I just don't want to call
you really out on the show.
But you've been collecting
these things,
and I think we should
talk about them
'cause it makes me laugh.
-Yeah.
So I started collecting VHSs
that were sealed in the box
like three years ago
'cause I was really high
one night and I thought --
I thought, 'cause, like,
listen to this, guys.
So in 2026, it'll be 20 years
since the last VHS
was made, right?
So 20 years goes by,
that's enough time
for people to be like,
"Oh, that was cool. Remember?"
Like vinyl.
-Yes.
-So I bought all the sealed ones
that exist,
like 3,000 to 5,000 tapes.
[ Laughter ]
You guys sound like my mom.
-No, no.
-No one believes in me.
No one believes in me.
-Look at this. This is --
-Oh, yeah, that's just --
yeah, that's just --
-Here's some of the packages
that arrived at your house.
-That's at my --
That's at my assistant's house.
And his girlfriend
is very mad at him.
-You have that --
-I have about 3,000 to 5,000.
But hear me out.
Hear me out.
So as of a month ago,
sealed VHSs are now going
for like 20 to 30 grand a pop.
Ooh!
-That's not --
-"Rocky" just sold
for like $27,000.
-What?
-Yes.
-You're serious?
-Yeah. It's my GameStop.
Like, this is my --
Like, dude, I own all of them.
-This is your Game--
-Dude, no one believed in me.
-Wow!
We believe in you now, Pete.
We believe in you.
-It's gonna happen, you guys.
-This is great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's a disaster.
-It's a -- Dude.
If it doesn't work, dude, I'm
gonna be on the road forever.
-It's a disaster, yeah.
Last time you were here, I was
so excited to have you here.
You were excited. You were about
to host "Saturday Night Live."
-Yeah.
-It was like, wow.
And then the writers'
strike happened.
-Of course. Yeah.
-And you weren't able to host.
-No.
And it was that week, actually.
-It was that week.
It's funny, any time
I have something
that I work really hard on
that I'm, like, really proud of,
either, like,
a national pandemic happens
and they're like,
"No premiere for you."
-Yeah.
-And then, yeah,
and then this writers'
strike happened.
So, yeah, I still don't think --
It might not happen.
-No, no, no. It's going to --
It's going to happen.
I'm excited about this.
How did you find out
that you were going to host?
-Oh, I got a classic Lorne text.
He was like,
"There's a rumor going around
that you're the host
for the premiere."
And he goes, "I guess it's true,
because I started it."
[ Laughter ]
-That's pretty good.
-I mean, he's --
-He's the best.
-He's the best with the liners.
And I know your mom is one
of your biggest supporters,
and I've seen her on the show.
Is she excited?
Is she coming?
-She's very excited.
She actually has been
on the show
almost as many times as I have.
Like, she's always ready
to go up.
-That's actually really funny.
-And I'm really excited
just because,
like, I'm trying to find my mom,
like, someone to date.
-Oh.
-Yeah.
She hasn't been with anybody
in like 23 years,
so, like, yeah.
-This is a big deal.
-Yeah, and she's a good catch.
-She is.
-Yeah.
-She's fantastic.
-Yeah, and it's, like, you know,
brand-new down there.
So, if...
[ Rim shot ]
If anybody --
No, I've been trying to --
Do you know anyone?
Like, I've been trying
to find someone nice,
you know, for my mom, so...
-Yeah, we have --
Do you have any
single people out there?
-Yeah. Well, no, not --
[ Audience cheering ]
No, not you guys.
-No, no, no.
No.
-No, yeah, someone --
-Out there, someone out there.
Who is she looking for?
What kind of man does she want?
-I don't know.
She's never really talked --
We're not --
We don't talk about that stuff.
But I really just want
someone to take care of her
and get her off of my hands.
[ Laughter ]
-But she will be there, right,
and supporting you?
-Oh, yeah.
-You know what I read?
It made me laugh
because my parents
did kind of a similar thing,
but is this true?
She made you take
the sanitation exam?
-Yes. And when I got "SNL,"
I called her and I was like,
"I'm going to be --
I got 'SNL,' Mom.
Like, holy crap.
Like, wow."
And she was like,
"Well, just so you know,
the garbageman test is at
the end of the month in case --"
So she -- Until about
three years ago,
every year. she would ask me
to take the garbageman test
just as, like, a backup.
-And how did you do?
-I didn't take it, but she would
always try to be like --
She's like,
"It's pretty cool, Peter
You get to, like, hang
outside of the, you know --"
-No, you get to
hang off the side.
She's like,
"That'd be good for you."
-You'd be good at that, yeah.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-My parents, same thing.
They go, "Jimmy,
we love your comedy career.
You want to be a comedian.
That's so cool.
Take the postal exam."
-Yeah, you get to drive
on the other side.
-I love --
You get to drive --
Your steering wheel's
on the other side.
You wear shorts to work.
I mean,
they got their own rules.
-It's an Irish thing.
-It's an --
-They don't believe in us.
No. Yeah, but look --
look at you now, though.
Hosting "Saturday Night Live,"
Mom.
-Yeah.
-This is a big deal.
-Oh, thanks. Yeah, I'm stoked.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-In your 20s.
You're turning --
You're turning 30.
-I'm going to be 30 in a month.
Isn't that scary?
-Wow. It's a milestone.
-Ohh!
-It's a milestone.
-Some people were like,
"I thought you were 40."
-No, no, no.
No, you're young, kid.
-No, it's scary.
-No.
-It's scary to turn 30.
-It's exciting.
-Yeah. I mean, it's over.
[ Laughter ]
No, because it's like
when you're 30,
like, if you mess up,
like, you're just, like,
a drug addict or an adult.
You know what I mean?
In your 20s, you could mess up
because, like, you know,
they're like,
"Oh, he's finding himself."
-But 30 means something.
-No, now if I mess up, it, like,
matters, you know, so...
-But, no, you're not
going to mess up.
-No, it'll be fine.
Yeah.
-I wanted to see you
'cause you were out
with two of my favorites,
John Mulaney and Jon Stewart.
-Oh, yeah, Stew.
-On tour with --
That's an unbelievable show.
-Yeah, they're great.
-You're great, too.
-No, no.
It's really fun
to go on the road with them.
And it's also fun to see --
You could tell immediately
who's there for who.
-Yeah.
-Like, you know.
Like, there's, like,
very respectful people
that are, like,
there to watch comedy,
and then people that are just
like, "Show us your [bleep]"
[ Laughter ]
-Who are Jon Stewart fans.
-Those are Jon Stewart fans.
-Jon Stewart fans, of course.
Yeah, yeah, of course.
-Yeah, yeah.
-That's what happens, yeah.
-So it's a very mixed audience.
-I'm so happy that
you're hosting the show.
I'm excited for you,
and you more than deserve it.
And Ice Spice is musical guest.
-Yeah, Ice Spice.
-It's a hot show this Saturday.
Pete Davidson,
ladies and gentlemen.
Catch him hosting
the season premiere
of "Saturday Night Live"
this weekend
with musical guest Ice Spice.
Troye Sivan joins us
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.